cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de will hunting avec en vedette robin
williams déjà un gros succès aux états
unis pour ce film qui concrétise d'une
certaine façon le rêve américain en
effet ces auteurs étaient totalement
inconnus ils ont finalement réussi non
seulement à vendre leur projet mais a
joué dans le film et aux côtés d'une
star robin williams qui fait prêter au
jeu pour un cachet modeste il était une
fois pascal deschamps bonjour je
m'appelle matt damon
j'ai coécrit will hunting passionnante
histoire que celle de will hunting un
orphelin des quartier ouvrier de boston
dont le quotidien se conjuguant cuite et
baston au bar du coin mais un petit
génie doué d'une intelligence
exceptionnelle qui lui permet de se
tirer de bien des mauvais pas il est
accordé le droit de parler pour ma
propre défense monsieur par la
constitution des états unis c'est ce
même regard à ton très personnel et a
donné la liberté au cas où vous l'auriez
oublié et le droit de l'ama respirer
je ne peux pas respirer à fond ce que
les lois sont propre étroites sans la
liberté l'homme est une syncope
l'homme est passionnante histoire que
celle de deux amis d'enfance devenus
acteurs qui écrivent ensemble un
scénario will hunting verra le jour
non sans peine au bout de cinq ans plus
d'une fois on s'est dit que cela ne se
ferait pas plus d'une fois des
producteurs ont essayé de nous virer du
film pour prendre d'autres acteurs alors
c'est un vrai bonheur de le voir
terminer si on en face à face que celui
de matt et robin la star le psy qui va
tenter d'aider le jeune rebelle à
choisir son destin
la mettons que vous êtes surpris en
pleine mer pour une grosse centaine le
ciel vous tombe sur la tête les vagues
s'écrase sur votre petit bateau les
rames vont bientôt sombre et vous
puissez la route froc pour chialer vous
avez peur vous êtes prêts à tout pour
vous en sortir
peut-être des nantis bravo c'est ça à
moi de faire mon boulot et arrêtent
demande empêché d'être que vous n'avez
pas la femme qu'il fallait être que tu
devrais fermer ta gueule lors de la
première scène de robin je me suis mise
à pleurer je regarde ben robin fut la
scène il nous voit et alors elle a mis
ses mains sur nos têtes
il nous a dit eh ben voilà vous avez
réussi pour faire un film comme ça on
accepte un sacré réductions de salaires
on peut pas avoir un salaire supérieur
au budget du film c'est dingue
les emprunts un rôle comme celui là
parce que c'est remarquablement écrite
moi je ferai tout pour avoir ce que tu
as comme tous les autres mais qu'ici
d'ailleurs on prendra ça comme une
insulte c'est encore là dans un temps
traîner ici c'est une de perdre
de temps pourquoi passionnant destin que
celui de lille où will hunting neuf fois
nominé aux oscars il ne manquerait plus
qu'il coiffe titanic au poteau pour que
le bonheur de maths et ben soit complet